so we want a different equation for
acceleration we wanted to show the
displacement equation is a wave function
the third one has to do with this result
here that we got for X double dot reason
to do it last week remember there's a
relationship between this and velocity
right mainly it's the derivative of now
remembers what goes in there halfway
square right okay
so let's take this idea right if X
double dot that that the derivative of
1/2 V squared should also be there okay
now I'm on a little space over here so
this is three on the differential
equation not acceleration buffle
velocity
okay so I'm going to start off with this
same statement this is the simple
harmonic motion statement okay but
instead X double dot I'm going to use
this derivative okay so that's with
respect to X which is good because the
right-hand side is also with respect to
X okay so we're going to get a
relationship here by integrating out now
like I said to you before um these ones
here you can actually quote but you're
going to get asked to show these right
so pay attention as I go through these
steps this is what you're going to have
to produce if I integrate both sides
with respect to X I'm going to get 1/2 a
squared over here what am I going to get
on the right-hand side text let's write
x is how it's going to go up and I'm
going to divide by the power all right
so I'm going to get minus N squared
there goes the power up and then I have
to divide by the new power so I'm also
good now I'm integrated so I'm going to
need to remember the constant so I'll
slide the constant on there
I'll divide it by 2 because everything
else is divided by 2 and peer pressure
that kind of things so there's a
constant okay now just have to go a
little bit further here if I multiply
through I'm going to get V squared is
minus N squared x squared plus C okay
now usually when you get a constant here
and a constant integration we're gonna
have to get rid of it somehow what could
we use to get rid of it well when we did
exponential growth or decay we tended to
use an initial condition T equals 0 and
population equals some such number okay
but can you see why an initial condition
isn't going to be a whole lot of use in
this particular situation can you see
because there's this situation of
something to a time right that's why
it's not differential equation it has to
do with displacement so what what you
have to do want to think about velocity
and displacement I had now relate to
each other
okay so simple harmonic motion it looks
like this right
now depending on what kinds of
coefficients we put on this for instance
changing the amplitude and that kind of
thing the velocity of this is going to
change all over the place it might be
quite fast like this or it could be a
slower sort of thing right so I'm not
going to know the actual concrete value
of the velocity at any particular point
along the graph except there are some
special places on this graph where I
absolutely know what the velocity is
even if I don't know anything about you
know what these numbers are okay what
are the special points where we know the
velocity which we know at these
extremities right these extreme
positions okay whatever kind of simple
harmonic motion it is we know that at
those spots the velocity should equal
zero right so the losses should equal
zero
where now what are those extreme
positions well based on what we've been
talking about before it's about where
you reach the edges of your adversity
right
so when X is equal to a or minus a as
you can see it don't matter because your
answer at both sides are getting the
same thing because velocity zero points
I can take this and this I can start you
did nothing to the time okay so I'm
going to put in zero squared equals
minus N squared a squared plus six
okay so advise your range this is what
I've got this is important this shows
that is C hanging off the end here it's
not just any random number it actually
has to do with n what does that define
and it defines a period right how
quickly it's oscillating and a is
amplitude right so how far it goes right
so if I rewrite this equation here based
on what I know now I could say V squared
is equal to du and here's my constant on
the end
okay so just tidy up a little bit
factoring out this n squared
that's a minus sign so I guess I can put
afterwards I'm going to get this result
okay so for instance they might ask you
to prove that the velocity squared of
some kind of particle that's moving is
you know for outside of 36 minus
x-square now what can you read off this
what can you read off and have a look
this corresponds to N squared ok n
square so in this case n would be 2
right so the period would be would be PI
right seconds or minutes or whatever
unit we're here
so period would be PI should take time
units ok in the same way it's 36 right
corresponds to my a squared so I can
read off here the amplitude should be 6
that's the effort to division that's
going to go between possible minus 6
okay right now let me emphasize again
this first characteristic here is the
most important one okay there I should
approve so I'll stand on the way they
ask you in principle have information
that's the one you want to go for okay
however these results caught so often I
want you to be able to recognize them
also you actually include them as a
proof but so you can see what they mean
and that these numbers don't catch you
by surprise you actually know what they
refer to
okay any question